hello America my name is Alan stone and
these are my top five YouTube videos the
first one that I'm gonna show you is
called the Campbell's Soup gospel I
don't know where it was filmed or why it
was filmed this wonderful woman loves
Campbell's soup as much as I do
[Music]
not talking about that lentil soup that
carrot soup talking about that campbell
soup so my second video is a GI Joe
parody when I was a kid they would have
PSA announcements during Saturday
morning cartoons and this one is I think
about dropped powerlines
obviously the dialogue has been over
dubbed for something completely
different
multi bottom star who wants a body
massage his best number 3 on my
countdown is James Blake's live version
of retrograde at the radio station KEXP
in Seattle Washington this dude is crazy
good and kxp is one of the dopest radio
stations in the entire world potentially
the entire universe and James blank
might be the greatest musician in the
said two universe as well
a few years to go number four on Allen
stones countdown for greatest youtube
videos of all time is a jurassic park
parity check it out it's funny I'm not
gonna tell you about it cuz then you
won't be surprised the number 5 video
for your fortunate eyes Oh America his
group loves video a ways to go this is
some very adorable
wonderfully funny and extremely charming
all wrapped into this nice little screen
called YouTube you go check it out
I love you very much and I hope to see
you very soon
smooches come on
watch what did he just say to us